The answer is that you can't tell.
This is a different type of combinatorial problem than the previous ones.
In the previous ones we had a fixed number of variables,
and we knew how many combinations we had for each variable.
In the zebra problem, there were 25 variables, and that's all there was.
We could enumerate all the combinations.
For the pouring problem we're trying to not fill static variables
but rather put together a sequence of actions to go from one state to the next.
We don't know how long that sequence is, and of course,
at each point we have 6 different options of different ways to go.
From each of those 6 more.
We know it's going to be roughly 6 to the something,
because we branch 6 at each point,
but we don't know what that x is, because we don't know how long the sequence is.
So that makes the problem slightly different.
If we want to be foraml, we call it a combinatorial optimization problem,
but usually we just called it a "search" problem.